herzlich willkommen zufolge 180 des faz
einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast für recht justiz und politik
heute am 6 10 oktober 2021 mein name ist
corinna budras und mit dabei ist wieder
da lorenz hallo ein herzliches
willkommen auch von mir
aus mitteilung haben wir heute nicht
mehr oder hast du noch was auf mich
haben will letzte woche hatte ich
ausnahmsweise mal keine technischen
probleme alles gut
ging herunter wie sonstwas wie wir
wollen jetzt unser team vorstellen die
sind sehr vielfältig diese woche wir
beginnen mit der sängerin britney spears
dem ist da unser jugend die bp hat sich
aus der fiesen umklammerung ihres vaters
gelöst und das hat natürlich auch
wirklich etliche rechtliche aspekte die
uns pia mal mehr erörtern wird im thema
der woche blicken wir auf die
strafrechtliche aufarbeitung des ns
unrechts regimes das nahm vor 75 jahren
seinen anfang mit den nürnberger
prozessen und ist jemand noch nicht zu
ende und dann zum schrieb realien sehr
aktuellen anlass dafür nämlich eine 96
jährige die flucht ergreift genau die
getürmt als die kz sekretärin muss ich
aber dennoch stellen sie wurde
aufgegriffen und in untersuchungshaft
gebracht da ist jetzt inzwischen wieder
raus aber jedenfalls diese ganzen dinge
werde ich mal besprechen mit dem
strafrechts professor christoph
safferling der uns wirklich auf
wunderbare art und weise einen großen
bogen schlägt zu den prozessen die
damals anfingen
1946 1945 sogar schon und die auch heute
noch wie gesagt die strafgerichte
beschäftigen ja und dann haben wir noch
unsere kategorie was kommt und dann
haben wir das gerechte urteil der woche
so genau wir kommen zum thema britney
spears was ja irgendwie weniger lustig
ist als dass sich eigentlich anhören
sollte wenn man über eine so berühmte
pop sängerin spricht wobei ich gar nicht
weiß ob es nur an unserem alter liegt
gucken hat das wird die frau so berühmt
finden sie das schon ein kurzer hören
würde nicht hörer ab um die hörerinnen
und hörer die wesentlich jünger sind als
wir mal ein bisschen abzuholen also
britney spears war ein absoluter
superstar so ab ende der 90er jahre und
da war sie selbst noch super jung und
wurde so ein bisschen aufgebaut als die
zwar sexy amerikanische junge frau die
sich aber wie bis zu eher auf sport und
klebt usw und das heißt die stand halt
von anfang an unter einem riesigen druck
also die war schon so ein bisschen als
kinderstar unterwegs und so und 1999
hatte sie dann einen riesenhit mit baby
one more time und ab da weil die frau
ein absoluter weltstar und standhält
permanent unter beobachtung von
millionen von paparazzi sozusagen und
wenn die mal feiern gegangen ist wenn
hieß es sofort der absturz der britney
spears und heran also das war schon echt
was los die stand unter unter massiver
beobachtung der öffentlichkeit und eben
von anfang an wohl auch ziemlich unter
der fuchtel ihres vaters der sich immer
sehr stark in ihrer karriere eingemischt
hat und dann kam es im jahr 2007 zu
einer absoluten vollkatastrophe
die sich jetzt erst langsam aufzulösen
beginnt und das ist der grund warum wir
eigentlich über britney spears schwer
und wer jetzt hier denkt wir werden zur
gala verkommen da muss man sagen nein
nein das ganze ist wirklich betreuungs
rechtlich irrsinnig spannend wir werden
auch gleich noch mal auf die
unterschiede zwischen deutschen und
amerikanischen betreuungsrecht zu
sprechen kommt also was ist da drüben
gibt kann ich schon angekündigt also in
deutschland gibt es das wort
vormundschaft eigentlich gar nicht
glaube ich zumindest nicht mehr für
volljährige menschen sondern wenn man in
deutschland irgendwie sozusagen
überwacht werden muss weil man seine
eigenen geschäfte nicht so ganz auf die
reihe kriegt dann nennt man das
hierzulande betreuung und die
möglichkeiten eines betreuers sind halt
auch viel viel viel geringer als ganz
offensichtlich in den vereinigten lange
denn im jahr 2008 ist britney spears
unter vormundschaft gestellt worden und
zwar unter die vormundschaft ihres
vaters hatte natürlich eine längere
vorgeschichte
2007 ist britney spears quasi quasi in
aller öffentlichkeit zusammen gebrochen
hat ein paparazzo verprügelt der vater
ihrer kinder hatte schon das sorgerecht
für die kinder und dann stand sie halt
da nach einer gescheiterten
suchttherapie ihre ehe war hinüber und
ist dann 2008 quasi öffentlich auf einer
trage in sicherheit sind das war
wirklich damals ein echter riesenskandal
und dann hat sie sich wohl selbst ein
gelassen darauf unter vormundschaft
gestellt zu werden und zwar wenn man
sozusagen in dem fall der gala und co
glauben darf weil sie zumindest das
besuchsrecht für ihre kinder animieren
wollte wie gesagt jetzt sorgerecht hatte
schon der vater und sie wollte in dem
sie sich unter die vormundschaft stellen
lassen zumindest das besuchsrecht für
die kinder sich sicher sie hat aber
damals schon gesagt ich bin ein verstand
mit einer vormundschaft aber bitte nicht
mein vater hat allerdings keine auf sie
gehört der vater der mann heißt jamie
spears wurde dann als vormund eingesetzt
und ist das geblieben seid nochmal 2008
also unfassbare 13 jahre lang hat der
vater nicht nur ihr vermögen verwaltet
sondern offenbar auch das ganze leben
von gott ja und wie ist das so zu sagen
eigentlich möglich denn tatsächlich das
amerikanische recht scheint ja
wesentlich schärfer in dieser hinsicht
zu sein also man gibt im grunde um seine
freiheit dann an der tür ab oder jetzt
bei viel genauer als das ist das ist
offenbar viel schärfer als im deutschen
recht und an dieser stelle möchte ich
ganz ganz dringend irgendwie empfehlen
den schwester podcast von der faz
nämlich den podcast für deutschland und
zwar vom zweiten september der hat sich
in einer kompletten folge ich glaube
eine dreiviertelstunde lang nur dem
thema britney spears gewidmet er hat
dabei auch nicht nur mit einem
aktivisten der free brittney bewegung
gesprochen der schon mal mit britney
spears auf der bühne stand sondern auch
mit einem deutschen fachanwalt für
erbrecht und einem vorsorge anwalt der
sehr sehr schön verglichen hat was nach
deutschen betreuungsrecht möglich wäre
und und das ist eben nicht möglich wäre
jemanden so massiv einzuschränken wie
jetzt bitten sbs da in ihrer
vormundschaft offenbar eingeschränkt
worden ist absolute höhe empfehlung
verlinken wir euch in den schoß eine
supertolle folge des auch ansonsten
übrigens sehr hörenswerten faz brocken
doch hier gehen grüße aus an den
kollegen simon strauss der die der folge
gemacht hat sehr hörenswert genau ich
habe mich sehr gefreut wirklich sehr
hörenswerte folge ich habe sie bis zur
letzten minute gehört und kann das auch
an dieser stelle nur empfehlen also wir
müssen natürlich ein bisschen mehr so
auf die rechtsfragen hier noch fixiert
aber es war schon seit jahren so dass es
im gerüchte gab dass britney spears da
eben nicht fröhlich und hat der
vormundschaft ihres vaters lebt sondern
dass sie wohl sehr sehr unglücklich war
und das hat sich dann formiert eine
bewegung die unter dem hashtag free
britney vierte das waren am anfang
irgendwie fans die er so ein bisschen
verschwörungstheorie zu stehen den
instagram account ausgewertet haben von
britney spears und gesagt habe das
klingt aber alles sehr sehr unglücklich
aber das wurde immer stärker ernst zu
nehmen und dann gab es ich glaube das
war sogar in diesem jahr 20 21 eine sehr
viel beachtete dokumentation the new
york times die hieß fremming britney und
da konnte auch erstmals nachgewiesen
werden dass britney spears schon seit
2014 versucht hat ihren vater als
vormund loszuwerden und mittlerweile hat
sich also aufgrund durchaus seriöser
recherchen herausgestellt das ebenbild
sbs zur einnahme von lithium gezwungen
worden ist obwohl sie das nicht
einnehmen wollte dass sie nach eigenen
angaben eine verhütungspille hatte die
sie nicht entfernen durfte also und sie
wurde sogar in ihrem schlafzimmer in
ihrer kommunikation überwacht also die
dürfte keine whatsapp nachricht
verschicken ohne dass die gelesen worden
ist die war wirklich wie im knast und
das wäre tatsächlich nach deutschen
betreuungsrecht so nicht denkbar sondern
nach deutschen betreuungsrecht sagt man
eben vor allem bei menschen die ja
offensichtlich dazu in der lage sind
zumindest noch im ansatz und normales
leben zu führen und vielleicht nur ich
sage mal etwas unglückliche
entscheidungen für sich selbst treffen
dass da vielleicht ein betreuer quasi
zur seite gestellt wird der sie der sie
so ein bisschen supportet und der
vielleicht auch entscheidungen übernimmt
jetzt zum beispiel größere
vermögenswerte betreffen oder so aber da
kann man zumindest noch ein normales
leben führen und da geht es dann eher so
ein rechtsgeschäfte und nicht zwingend
darum dass man sozusagen in der tat und
es ist auch zeitlich beschränkten bzw
wird immer wieder muss immer wieder
verlängert werden dann nach deutschem
recht das heißt es gibt jetzt hier kein
automatismus dass wenn man einmal ein
betreuer
der dann vor sie gar nicht mehr von der
seite war echt sondern das wird immer
wieder überprüft ob das überhaupt noch
nötig ist denn erwachsene menschen
sollen tatsächlich in der lage sein
dauerhaft ihre geschäft eigentlich
selbst zu regeln und der betreuer ist
nur dafür da quasi soja krisen zu
überstehen nach deutschem recht aber
eben anders in den vereinigten staaten
wirklich auch ziemlich erschüttert was
da zu hören ist übrigens der hinweis mit
instagram
sehr interessant auch das habe ich vor
allen dingen aus der folge der kollegen
der im podcast für deutschland gelernt
welche rolle instagram eigentlich in dem
heutigen leben der stars eben
gespielt navi wie selbst viel
selbstbestimmter die eigentlich heute
agieren können und sich selbst
präsentieren können im vergleich zu
damals nur wo es tatsächlich sehr sehr
stark paparazzo getrieben war
starr quasi die medien da ihr eigenen
spin gedreht haben und die hat die stars
eigentlich gar nicht ihr eigenes leben
richtig präsentieren konnten so wie sie
es gerne hätten
also genau das machen natürlich soziale
medien heute ganz anders möglich das
heißt heute können sich auch sehr junge
menschen eben auf die art und weise
präsentieren die ihm gefällt und in der
auf der sie sich präsentieren wollen und
nicht die lesart die die kooperation
nehmen müssen das ist halt schon eine
ganz andere zeit das kann man sich
vielleicht heute mit den sozialen medien
gar nicht mehr so vorstellen nun wenn
man dann eben keinen sehr guten pr
berater hatte damals der ein in das
richtige licht gerückt hat und eine gute
tipps gegeben hat sondern womöglich noch
ein schlechter berater wie den eigenen
vater der offenbar hier nicht den
großartigsten job der welt gemacht hat
dann stand man unter einem druck den man
sich heute vielleicht so so und wie ging
es dann weiter also es gab jetzt dann
die ersten hinweise darauf dass das
alles wesentlich schlimmer ist als man
sich das vorstellt und dann war es damit
aber noch nicht getan das ganze ist ja
natürlich ein rechtlicher prozess die
ablösung vom
vom vater von dem betreuer als solchen
wie ging das vonstatten also in den usa
ist es offenbar so dass man grundlegend
als mündel also quasi als unter
betreuung gestellt
selbst nachweisen muss dass es einem
jetzt wieder gut geht also es war uns
nicht so ganz final möglich dass
rauszukriegen ob es rechtlich
tatsächlich gar nicht vorgesehen ist
dass zum beispiel regelmäßige
überprüfung der betreuung stattfinden
aber es ist auf jeden fall so dass
derjenige der unter betreuung gestellt
ist die verantwortung dafür trägt aus
der betreuung wieder rauszukommen hier
war es aber offenbar anders der vater
von britney spears hat wohl aufgrund des
öffentlichen drucks der immer mehr
zunahm also diese bewegung free brittney
wurde immer größer immer stärker ist
spielte sich auch nicht mehr nur in
sozialen medien ab sondern eben auch
draußen auf der straße und spätestens
mit dieser in new york times doku
fremming britney geriet dann james
pearce wohl sehr unter druck und er hat
dann offenbar selbst
beantragt die vormundschaft zu beenden
also seine anwältin hatte beantragt
nicht ihn als vormund abzusetzen sondern
die gesamte vormundschaft zu beenden das
ist jetzt aber erstmal nicht passiert
sondern die richterin hat nur den vater
jamie spears als vormund von britney
abgesetzt und einen anderen vormund
eingesetzt dass es offensichtlich ein
wirtschaftsprüfer der ist jetzt
eingesetzt worden als vorläufiger
vermögensverwalter man darf allerdings
mit fug und recht davon ausgehen dass
der eben nicht dafür zuständig sein wird
das gesamte leben von britney spears zu
kontrollieren die jetzt derzeit auch
schon im urlaub ist und sich mit vielen
social media postings bei ihren fans
dafür bedankt dass die auch aus ihrer
sicht daran mitgewirkt haben dass die
dass sie jetzt quasi frei ist nun also
free bitten er hat er jetzt ein erfolg
gefeiert wie fiel die wahl auf diesen
wirtschaftsprüfer das kann ich dir nicht
sagen oder ist auch zumindest deutschen
medien nicht zu entnehmen was deutschen
medien zu entnehmen war und das fand ich
sehr spannend
ist die tatsache dass jetzt der anwalt
von britney spears die gesamten
unterlagen überprüfen kann
die ihr vater in den letzten 13 jahren
quasi angesammelt hat das heißt eben
diese sozusagen immer gemunkelt vorwürfe
der bereichere sich selbst und so weiter
an den enormen vermögen von britney
spears das kann wohl jetzt alles
überprüft werden und das soll wohl das
konnte ich wie gesagt rechtlich im
amerikanischen recht nicht nachprüfen
das soll aber eben daran liegen dass
eben nicht die gesamte vormundschaft
schon beendet wurde sondern nur dass nur
der vormund ausgetauscht wurde dadurch
hat jetzt britney spears anwalt die
möglichkeit eben einsicht in all diese
unterlagen zu nehmen ausnahme natürlich
die kommunikation mit seinen anwälten
also das unterliegt daneben dem liege
privileg ansonsten können die sich das
jetzt anschauen und zwar bis zum
nächsten termin mindestens der ist für
den 12 november terminiert
und dann wird ihr anwalt wohin antrag
auf eine komplette beendigung der
vormundschaft vorlegen da muss man dann
irgendwie schauen ob das funktionieren
wird denn wie gesagt der unter
vormundschaft stehende trägt die
beweislast dafür dass er in einem klaren
geistigen zustand ist und sozusagen
geschäftsfähig ist also keine keine
betreuung mehr braucht und britney
spears hat wohl schon sehr deutlich
gesagt dass sie sich nicht begutachten
lassen will das heißt da ist wohl noch
nicht ganz klar ob dann tatsächlich
diese vormundschaft insgesamt auch
beendet werden wird sie hat im juni und
im juli jeweils vor gericht einmal
ausgesagt in teilen auch nur
zugeschaltet und das muss sehr
herzzerreißend gewesen sein also da hat
sie wirklich
geweint hat geschildert wie ihr leben
stattgefunden hat usw und da hat die
richterin sich dann jetzt relativ
schnell überzeugen lassen zu sagen dass
dieser zustand so jedenfalls nicht
haltbar ist wie gesagt nächster termin
findet im november statt und dann muss
man gucken ob die gesamte betreuung
aufgehoben werden wird oder ob es
vielleicht bei der einen
vermögensbetreuung dann bleibt aber und
deshalb haben wir das unter anderem auch
aufgegriffen es gibt jetzt die idee und
zwar von republikanern und demokraten
gemeinsam einen so genannten free
britney act aufzusetzen der den
missbrauch in einer vormundschaft
verhindern soll und wie gesagt wir haben
das nur so ein bisschen an gerissen weil
es eben auch nur in teilen für uns jetzt
überprüfbar ist wie weit gehen da das us
amerikanische recht wirklich ist aber es
scheint so zu sein dass eben von der
beweislast des mündels dafür dass man
wieder normal ist bis hin zu nicht
regelmäßigen über prüfungen dieses
vormundschaftsrecht quasi tür und tor
öffnet für den für den missbrauch eines
betreuers und das oder offensichtlich
mit diesem free britney act über den es
auch sehr große einigkeit zu geben
scheint verändert werden und das fanden
wir so spannend dass wir dieses
ansonsten gala tratsch und klatsch und
tratsch thema unbedingt mal aufgreifen
wolle ja in der tat und es geht ja auch
zu herzen ja und da sieht man auch mal
wie tatsächlich recht im alltag
eingreift und zwar nicht zu knapp ja und
es da große unterschiede zwischen den
systemen geben kann und warum das in den
vereinigten staaten wirklich noch also
stark eingreift ist mir ehrlich gesagt
ein rätsel
wäre in der tat interessant mal raus zu
kriegen was für historische gründe
deshalb weil es eigentlich mit der
kultur mit der us amerikanischen kultur
des der freiheit und eigenständigkeit
und autonomie überhaupt nicht zu
vereinbaren raum zu vereinen
bemerkenswert ja absolut und man kann
sich eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen
wenn das jemandem passieren kann der so
sehr in der öffentlichkeit steht wie das
nie britney spears tut dann da kann man
sich ja gar nicht vorstellen was das mit
anderen menschen macht gegeben sehr
richtig ja also das zu diesem thema und
jetzt kommen wir zum schwerpunkt der
woche ein ganz ganz anderes thema da
müssen wir sozusagen emotional jetzt
nochmal komplett umschalten denn jetzt
schalten wir zurück und gucken auf das
ns unrecht wie es im zweiten weltkrieg
die menschheit erschüttert hat muss man
ja sagen und was dafür strafrechtliche
konsequenzen daraus gezogen worden
[Musik]
das heikle thema der strafrechtlichen
aufarbeitung von ns unrecht möchte ich
nun mit professor christoph safferling
besprechen er ist lehrstuhlinhaber für
strafrecht und völkerrecht an der
friedrich alexander universität erlangen
nürnberg und hat sich in seiner
beruflichen laufbahn schon viel mit
prozessen gegen kriegsverbrecher und
insbesondere mit dem nürnberger
prozessen beschäftigt der safferling
schön dass sie sich heute die zeit
nehmen ja ich freue mich auf das bevor
wir gleich zu den aktuellen
strafprozessen kommen die bei bald gegen
den 100 jahre einen wachmann und eine 96
jahre alte kz sekretärin beginnen
blicken wir doch noch einmal zurück von
75 jahren begann die aufarbeitung der
deutschen verbrechen im zweiten
weltkrieg mit den nürnberger prozessen
er musste sich damals eigentlich
verantworten und vor wem ja das ist ja
wirklich eine sensationelle geschichte
die sich damals abgespielt hat
sensationell vor dem hintergrund des
damals geltenden völkerrecht denn
sicherlich weil es vorher usus dass man
nach irischen auseinandersetzungen den
friedensverträgen er am das team gewährt
hat sich halt ich quasi verziehen hat
und dass das nicht mehr möglich war nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg das hat die
alliierten im grunde schon 1943 auf den
weg gebracht in der sogenannten moskauer
deklaration hatte man kritisch
entschieden dass man strafrechtlich
vorgehen muss gegen die kriegsverbrecher
gerade eben von nazi-deutschland und
hatte man sicherlich die vorstellung als
dann auch der krieg zu ende ging man
würde dass adolf hitler und
himmler und unter bis vor die in dem
gericht vor den richter schleppen können
aber das war dann natürlich nicht mehr
möglich die hatten sich entsprechend
durch selbstmord einer justiziellen
aufarbeitung in zügen aber man hat ja
immer noch dann den den entschluss
gefasst auch gemeinsamen also in einer
internationalen anstrengung einen
gerichtshof zu kreieren
und hier eben die noch überlebenden
nazi-kriegsverbrecher entsprechend
strafrechtlich zur verantwortung zu
ziehen die galionsfigur auf in diesem
prozess war sicherlich hermann göring
den politisch und auch militärisch eine
führungsperson in der nsdap und dem
deutschen reich war und danach gab es
noch etliche andere personen wie rudolf
heß den stellvertreter hitlers in der
partei und auch zb albert speer ja der
reichs rüstungsminister und der bekannte
architekt und eine andere militärs und
auch julius streicher der unsägliche
propagandist herausgeber des stürmers
ein unerträglicher an die süd also diese
diese personen wurden vor einem
internationalen strafgerichtshof der
extra dafür geschaffen worden ist dann
hier angeklagt wegen das verbrechen des
angriffskriegs kriegsverbrechen und
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
und das begann eben 1945 also ganz
unmittelbar nach kriegsende bereits am
20 november und endete dann mit dem
urteilsspruch dass ihr kind denken wir
jetzt gerade daran dass es vor 75 jahren
war am 30 september und am ersten zehn
oder daneben elf dieser
angeklagten auch zum tode verurteilt
worden sind und dann gab es allerdings
auch drei freisprüche und zeitige
freiheitsstrafe
also das war der beginn dieser
strafrechtlichen aufarbeitung
das war aber sozusagen dann auch nicht
ad acta gelegt damit sondern es folgten
sehr sehr viele weitere prozesse in
nürnberg die sogenannten nürnberger
nachfolgeprozesse das war dann aber
keine internationalen prozesse mehr
sondern amerikanische militär und auch
aktionen ja
nun war der nürnberger prozesse in der
tat sehr ungewöhnlich welche bedeutung
hatte denn in der rechtsgeschichte
eingenommen im weiteren verlauf der
geschichte zeigt sich ja dann auch dass
diese prinzipien die jetzt hier zum
ersten mal gegen deutsche
kriegsverbrecher angewendet worden sind
als internationale prinzipien eben auch
völkerrechtlich
anerkannt worden sind und für sozusagen
immer
aufgerichtet worden sind das hat dann ja
dauert bis sie dann sozusagen wieder
durchgesetzt worden sind in jugoslawien
strafgerichtshof dann 19 93 aber die
idee von damals die idee wurde nicht
losgelassen sondern konnte sich dann
nach ende des ost west konfliktes dann
wirklich konnte dann wirklich
durchbrechen und und jetzt als
internationaler standard wie war kann
sich denn eigentlich die angeklagten vor
gericht geriert ja das ist eine sehr
interessante frage
also die die verteidigungsstrategien die
wir in nürnberg erleben sind allesamt
getragen von einem großen portion an
uneinsichtigkeit also man hatte so ein
bisschen die tendenz natürlich nicht nur
adolf hitler der em nicht mehr da war
sondern eben auch auf hermann bröring
die schuld abzuwälzen aber man konnte
sich natürlich nicht überzeugen damit
herausreden auch auf dieser ebene
jedenfalls nicht man wusste von diesen
ganzen verbrechen nichts und man hatte
keine ahnung dass sein krieg geplant ist
und man hatte keine ahnung von von den
erschießungskommandos da gerade in
osteuropa also das war natürlich nicht
überzeugend aber es wurde versucht der
einzige der so ein stück weit ein sich
gezeigt hat war war war das spiel
der auch sonst so den zynga den galanten
intellektuellen gegeben hat diese
verteidigungsstrategie wie sich als sehr
erfolgreicher wurde ja nicht zum tode
verurteilt sondern nur zu 20 jahren
freiheitsstrafe die er dann entspannter
in berliner gefängnis abgesessen hat bis
die ganzen 20 jahre und danach kam er
dann sozusagen die dazu die deutsche
gesellschaft und wurde dann hier
herumgereicht als einer der erklärer und
chef des nationalsozialistischen
deutschlands und wie wir jetzt also
wissen hat er uns ja alle an der nase
herumgeführt und sich immer wieder
selber ex kopiert und wir können aber
belegen dass er alles müssen von den
aktions lagern über die zwangsarbeiter
projekte und die programme
entschuldigung und und die
rüstungsindustrie et cetera wusste
einfach alles und war eingeweiht inneren
kreis um adolf hitler aber er hat es
geschafft durch eine geschickte
verteidigung sicht also ein bisschen
heraus zu lavieren aber er war eben auch
der einzige der so ein stück weit eben
ja schuld eingestehen ist vielleicht
schon fast ein bisschen viel ja aber so
ein stück weit zu bestanden hat bei den
anderen war da kein keinen funken von
von einsicht oder reue zu und wie war es
bei der bevölkerung wie hat die deutsche
bevölkerung auf diese verfahren geblickt
die ja wie sie richtig sagen wir
ungewöhnlich waren auch für diese zeit
ja also stellen sie sich deutschland im
sommer und dann im herbst 45 im frühjahr
46 vor
das war ein zerstörtes land vom krieg
gebeutelte politisch moralisch am ende
und da gibt es so ein verfahren das
natürlich entsprechend auch in den
medien ja soweit die verfügbaren zeitung
und und kinos die er dann wieder
aufgebaut worden sind usw da war das
natürlich präsent und wurde von den
alliierten ja entsprechend auch
propagiert ja es sollte ja auch ein
stück weit
amerikanischen senat uk des deutschen
volkes und sozusagen sein und das war
eben auch der nürnberger prozesse anlass
war der startpunkt dieses
erziehungsprogramm es den rc optionen
hat funktioniert
also wenn sie sich die umfragen
anschauen in den ersten in dem ersten
jahr da war man eigentlich sehr dafür
dass dieser prozess stattfindet und das
war auch eine ganz bequemen situation
das kann man glaube ich ganz gut
erklären weil jeder deutsche jede
deutsche konnte auch diese 21 personen
zeigen die da in nürnberg an der auf der
anklagebank sagen und sagen die sind
schuld die sind schuld für diesen krieg
die sind auch schuld für mein unheil was
ich jetzt zu ertragen habe für die
schwierigkeiten des aufbaus die haben
alles kaputtgemacht
das könnte man dann entsprechen so
extender mit werden und in diesem
zeitraum war dieser prozess sehr
anerkannt das änderte sich dann als das
weitere entnazifizierung programm bann
brach und dann jeder einzelne sich
rechtfertigen musste bis hin eben dann
zur ratifizierung kammern und fragebögen
und so weiter wo ihn der einzelne der
mitglied war und wie 89 millionen
mitglieder der nsdap
sich dafür rechtfertigen musste dann
wendete sich das blatt und man fühlt es
sich eben dann selber auf der
anklagebank zu ein stückchen und dann
hat man angefangen das kritisch sie
haben ja auch am anfang sehr schön
geschildert wie das hier tatsächlich
sehr sich auf die kriegsverbrechen als
solche konzentrierten in dem ersten
prozess spielte tatsächlich die die
fürchterlichen unmenschlichen zustände
in den vernichtungslagern
nur ganz am rande eine rolle
also das stimmt aus der heutigen
perspektive wo sicherlich der der
holocaust als das schlimmste verbrechen
der menschheitsgeschichte sehr stark im
vordergrund steht wenn wir an dem
zweiten weltkrieg auch denken und
nationalsozialismus in deutschland
denken der hatte in im nürnberger
prozess nicht diese wer nicht diese
stellung das lag an verschiedenen dingen
zunächst einmal war gerade von
amerikanischer seite aus die
kriminalisierung des angriffskriegs das
hauptziel dieses prozesses also man
wollte verhindern dass in zukunft weiter
in europa kriege geführt werden oder
weltweit wir hatten ja in japanischen
kontext ein vergleichbares problem und
dann ja auch einen vergleichbaren
prozess in diesem so genannte bio
tribunal
das war der eine und der andere kunde
wenn man sich wieder vorstellt so
unmittelbar nach kriegsende
offensichtlich war da auch noch gar
nicht so viel bekannt also
beispielsweise das protokoll der wannsee
konferenz in der ja dann die endlösung
der judenfrage wie sie da genannt wurde
festgelegt worden ist politisch
festgelegt worden ist dieses protokoll
tauchte erst 1947 auf also dass da
wirklich eine systematische angeordnete
industrielle vernichtung von juden und
anderen
minderheiten hier geplant waren
angeordnet war das war 1945 46 so noch
nicht bekannten wahrscheinlich konnte
man auch obwohl man bilder von der
befreiung von contec-x lange hat der
money raten hat man gezeigt aber man
konnte das glaube ich auch irgendwie
nicht glauben oder nicht war das ist
jedenfalls mein eindruck wenn ich die
prozess dokument
es gab ja tatsächlich fotos von der
befreiung von auschwitz zum beispiel
aber also denn die jetzt wie auch immer
wieder zu den jahrestagen natürlich
spätestens dann immer wieder zeigen die
muss es ja damals auch gegeben haben
aber interessant dass es das im
strafverfahren zumindest wirklich nur am
rande eine rolle spielte wie ging es
denn da weiter also der nächste
meilenstein waren hier war er dann der
auschwitz prozess in frankfurt in dem
sich nicht mehr nazi größen sondern die
verbrecher vor ort verantworten mussten
als wachleute zum beispiel
das war dann nicht mehr das
kriegsverbrechertribunal der
siegermächte sondern ein deutsches
strafgericht hat damit eigentlich die
strafrechtliche aufarbeitung begonnen
oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen
die strafrechtliche aufarbeitung begann
eigentlich parallel zum nürnberger
hauptkriegsverbrecherprozess und die
dann sich anschließenden weiteren
prozesse in den besatzungszonen
auch die deutsche justiz die ja im
spätsommer und herbst 1945 wieder
aufgebaut wurde ja man braucht ja auch
eine zivile strafjustiz und eine
zivilgerichtsbarkeit wurde in den
ländern ja dann schon wieder eröffnet
auch dort fanden
kriegsverbrecherprozesse stadt teilweise
auch unter anwendung der gleichen
kriterien blieben da auch
kriegsverbrecher prozess als teilweise
auch wegen verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit wurde vor deutschen
gerichten
anklage erhoben gegen deutsche
kriegsverbrecher das gab es schon dass
das schlief aber dann nach gründung der
bundesrepublik sehr schnell ein also die
bundesrepublik deutschland hatte ja und
das den sie auch an allen aussagen klar
die devise wir blicken jetzt nach vorne
und wenn man ein neues reich gründen
jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben
gesprochen dann vergisst man die
verbrechen der vergangenheit aber dass
aussagen von allen aber in dieser in
dieser richtung gibt es also das lief
eigentlich dann relativ rasch wieder ein
und es fing 1958 wieder an als man
eigentlich schon den eindruck hatte dass
kriegsverbrecher problem sei irgendwie
gelöst als man eben in stuttgart darauf
aufmerksam wurde dass es hier doch
etliche personen gab die an
einsatzgruppen vor allem teilgenommen
hatten also an erschießungen in gerade
in der ukraine und anderen
osteuropäischen staaten teilgenommen
haben wodurch tausende
tausende von personen erschossen worden
sind durch diese einsatzgruppen dass
diese immer noch in anführungszeichen
unter uns leben also die mörder sind
noch unter uns das war dann so ein
schlagwort und in den so genannten ulmer
einsatzgruppen prozess von 1958 wurde
das erstmals jetzt vor einem
bundesrepublikanische gericht in
vergleichsweise großer medialer
aufmerksamkeit dann durchgehend
durchgeführt die konsequenz war dass man
in ludwigsburg eine zentrale stelle
gegründet hat um diese ermittlungen für
gegen gegen ns verbrecher zu
konzentrieren und sozusagen zu zu
beschleunigen denn die verjährung drohte
jahr nach dem deutschen recht galt auch
auf den mord eine 20 jährige
verjährungsfrist sei es wenn man von
1945 anfängt zu rechnen dann wäre eben
965 dann die verjährung auch für
schlimme mordtaten eingetreten und das
wollte man entsprechend nicht dulden
sondern wollte davor eben mit mit großer
schlagkraft hier ermittlungen
durchführen und in diesem zuge kam es
dann eben auch zum auschwitz prozess den
sie gerade angesprochen haben das war
dann sicherlich mit der spektakulärste
aber denken auch daran dass kurz vorher
ja in jerusalem gegen adolf eichmann
prozessiert worden ist auch ein prozess
der auch in deutschland sehr hohe
mediale aufmerksamkeit erfahren hat und
dann stellen sie sich auch wieder vor
dass wir jetzt schon 15 jahre nach
kriegsende mit generation und person zu
tun haben die nicht mehr diese
erinnerungen haben die nicht aktiv am
krieg beteiligt waren eine neue
generation
eine generation auch von leuten die viel
vergessen wollte und die sind jetzt
wieder konfrontiert und noch einmal auf
ganz brutale art und weise garantiert
mit zeugenaussagen von überlebenden von
auschwitz die berichten was da passiert
ist und dass das lastet schwer also die
deutsche gesellschaft ist für die ist
das wirklich fast unerträglich die
politik versucht sich da so ein bisschen
versucht ein bisschen ruhm zu lavieren
aber in der konsequenz führt das
letztlich zu diesen großen
gesellschaftlichen verwerfungen die dann
bis in die neue volte von 1968 in der
tat wo denn deutschland quasi gespalten
waren quasi den nazis oder auch der
generation die das bewusst wahrgenommen
hat sich vielleicht auch fragen musste
was hat sie da eigentlich nicht sehen
hören warum ist sie nicht eingeschritten
das schon alleine essen eine schwere
bürde und den jüngeren die einfach nicht
ertragen konnten und auch nicht dulden
wollten wie die alten sich sozusagen da
zurückhalten und keine aufarbeitung
haben wollen das war in der tat auch im
auschwitz-prozess oder angelegt
beziehungsweise das war ein ein
startpunkt für diese weitere entwicklung
dann ja dass das traurige ist dann aber
dass diese also auch der die die
intention die 1958 in der gründung der
zentralstelle in ludwigsburg ja
hier dahinter stand und auch dann
auschwitz prozesse und andere prozesse
geführt worden sind die äbte sehr
schnell wieder ab und kam den kunden zum
vollkommenen liegen 1968 als durch eine
vermeintliche gesetzgebungs panne dann
auch der bundesgerichtshof
1969 entschieden hat die meisten dieser
taten sind verjährt
und das war letztlich ein auszug auch
der konsum sieben kreise in deutschland
die wollten das so dass also allenfalls
die spitze der ganz grausamen jedoch
verfolgt werden aber dass der normale in
anführungszeichen mitläufer dass der
nicht mehr strafrechtlich verfolgt wird
und das wurde dann im grunde 08 und 1669
kam dann die weitere verfolgung von
nationalsozialistischen gewaltverbrechen
komplett zum ende
wie hat sich denn die rechtsprechung
dann gewandet in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten denn jetzt fällt es
wesentlich leichter
auch diese mitläufer wie sie es eben
neuer schreibtischtäter zu verurteilen
was ist da passiert ja
also man muss da vielleicht noch zwei
dinge aus der zwischenzeit sozusagen von
1969 bis dann 2008 letztlich noch mal
beachten das eine ist diese von mir
vorhin genannte zentrale stelle in
ludwigsburg die eben ermittlungen
durchführen sollte zur
gegen die gegen die kriegsverbrechen von
deutscher seite aus diese zentrale
stelle wurde nie geschlossen sie gibt es
immer noch und die hat also die ganze
zeit informationen gesammelt und
ermittelt das schon ein politisches
statement vielleicht hat man die stelle
auch eine zeit lang vergessen gehabt
oder so aber die hat die ganze zeit
ermittelt dass zum einen und zum anderen
kam dann die wiedervereinigung und dann
hatte man sein plötzlich das problem
dass man hier junge soldaten hatte die
an der grenze ddr brd den grenzübertritt
waffengewalt verhindert haben und dann
bietet sich ihm die frage waren die
strafrechtlich verantwortlich war hier
ein letztlich einen verstoß gegen
menschenrechte derart dass das man die
bestrafen muss also die sogenannten
mauerschützenprozess und hier findet
jetzt tatsächlich von der rechtsprechung
seiten denken statt und es wird also
wenn man vorher immer gesucht dann nach
exkursionen der der nazi täter hat man
jetzt eben wie eindeutig gesagt nee die
menschenrechtliche situation hätte sich
doch jetzt auch so stark konsolidiert
das war ein verstoß gegen gegen
menschenrechte ich vereinfache jetzt ein
bisschen das strafrecht ich ganz ganz
kompliziert aber es gibt hier keine
rechtfertigung für den waffengebrauch an
der grenze um ausreisewillige hier zu
öffnen und die und so wurden
argumentationen auf beiden seiten sowohl
bei den mauerschützen als auch bei dem
personal was der eingebunden war in der
vernichtung der juden zb er immer dass
der befehl kam von oben ich habe mir nur
das gemacht was man mir gesagt hat
ja ganz genau und hier wird dann eben
jetzt festgestellt während man bei den
national schütze das gewaltverbrechen
der bereit war das zu akzeptieren weil
man das bei den mauerschützen im nicht
mehr und sagte dick ist der befehl war
in einem maße menschenrechtswidrig das
hättest du soldat erkennen müssen und
ich widersetzen müssen also ist jetzt
die argumentation dann beruft sich dann
auch die so genannte gebuchte formel
gustav radbruch justizminister in der
weimarer republik und weil sie ja
bekannter rechtsphilosoph und
strafrechts professor in heidelberg der
hatte in 19 46 so eine so eine formel
entwickelt dass er gesagt hat also
dieses himmel schreiende unrecht kann
nicht als recht gelten und dem folgt
dann der bundesgerichtshof so und mit
dem mitglied im hintergrund nun kam es
dann eben 2008 zu einem ganz
interessanten vorfall das eben ein
vermeintlicher kriegsverbrecher john
demjanjuk
der im kz sobibor als wachmann
gearbeitet hat von den usa ausgeliefert
werden sollte nach nach deutschland und
man konnte sich in deutschland hier
jetzt nicht verweigern musste den
sozusagen hier aufnehmen und musste
ihnen dann auch den prozess machen weil
die vorwürfe die man eher hatte und die
erkenntnis die man hatte auch seitens in
dieser ludwigsburger zentralstelle die
waren schon entsprechend erdrückend und
vor dem landgericht münchen zwei wurde
dann entsprechend ein prozess
durchgeführt und es wurde festgestellt
dass demjanjuk also hier wegen der
weniger tötung in der massentötungen im
konzentrationslager als wachmann
mitverantwortlich ist dieses dieser
prozess wurde leider oder dieses urteil
wurde leider nicht rechtskräftig denn
der bundesgerichtshof konnte über die
revision nicht mehr entscheiden denn
jürgens vorher gestorben da wurden
verfahren beendet aber jetzt war mal
hier eine stellungnahme eines deutschen
gerichtes das eben gesagt hat wir müssen
diese fälle wenn sie denn auf kommen
noch einmal anschauen wir sehen jetzt
auch diese ganzen unterstützungs taten
anders als das vielleicht 50 jahre
vorher der fall war und man ist dann das
tatsächlich auch nur die zentralstelle
in pittsburgh verschiedene fälle dann
wieder aufgerollt worden sind der
wichtigste wahl werden oskar grünen ein
wärter auch im kz auschwitz der auch
dort als buchhalter gearbeitet hat und
dieser prozess
am landgericht lüneburg kam dann auch
zum bundesgerichtshof der
bundesgerichtshof hat die rechtsprechung
letztlich die ihn schon im januar
angestoßen worden bis bestätigt und
gesagt ja derjenige der hier an der an
der kz bauer wache steht und der der
auch im büro für die verwaltung der ss
angelegenheiten arbeitet der macht sich
mitschuldig an der gesamt organisation
und durchführung eines
menschenverachtenden vernichtungswillen
konzentrationslagers und ist deswegen
wegen als gehilfe an diesen mordaktionen
entsprechend dann
also da haben wir eigentlich relativ
spät einen kompletten umschwung in der
rechtsprechung der jetzt dazu führt dass
wir schon seit einiger zeit aber auch
jetzt wieder gewalt
verfahren sehen ging hochbetagte
ehemalige mitarbeiter also wir haben wie
gesagt am morgigen donnerstag beginnt
der das verfahren gegen einen
hundertjährigen wachmann wir haben jetzt
hier gerade gesehen in den vergangenen
tagen hat für aufregung gesorgt dass
eine 96-jährige
kz
sekretärin
getürmt ist ja aus ihrem pflegeheim weil
sie sich dem verfahren nicht stellen
wurde sie wurde dann
aufgegriffen und in untersuchungshaft
gebracht da ist jetzt inzwischen wieder
raus muss eine fußfessel tragen bisher
am 19 oktober
weitergehen kann der prozess oder
richtig starten kann dann sicher erst
verantworten also warum ist es noch
richtig die trotzdem auch in diesem
hohen alter noch vor gericht zu stellen
also es ist natürlich nicht ganz
unproblematisch aus verschiedenen
gründen zum einen darf man jetzt auch
als sozusagen deutsche justiz nicht
denken man könnte jetzt die versäumnisse
der jahrzehnte
nach 1969 sozusagen jetzt aufarbeiten
indem man jetzt alte herrschaften die
noch die noch am leben sind hier auf die
anklagebank setzt also das versäumnis
bleibt auf jeden fall bestehen auf der
anderen seite
ist das natürlich auch so und unser
ehemaliger justizminister und jetzt
außenminister heiko maas hat mal gesagt
dass niemand ein recht hat auf einen
auf einen ruhigen lebensabend hatten
unglaublich ausgedrückt der solche
verbrechen begangen hat oder an solchen
verbrechen mitgewirkt hat und ich glaube
das ist wichtig das hat man nicht man
muss sich dann auch wenn die taten lange
her sind damit konfrontieren lassen
und man muss ein verfahren durchführen
ich halte das für eine nicht nur richtig
ist sondern auch moralische
notwendigkeit
insbesondere auch für die vielen opfer
die er auch noch die überlebenden ja die
ja auch noch hoch betagt am liebsten und
irgendwann dann gegenüber das signal
zeigen kann wir haben da zwei jahrzehnte
lang nichts gemacht aber wir tolerieren
dass nicht das passt nicht in die
gesellschaft wir wollen nicht dass so
etwas jemals wieder passiert die andere
frage die sich dann anschließt ist
natürlich die wie hart muss man dann
dieses urteil auch vollstrecken und da
wäre ich dann eher großzügig sein es
soll jetzt auch niemand bedingt dann die
letzten zwei jahre vielleicht verbleiben
im gefängnis verbringen aber ein urteil
ein verfahren und ein urteil sollte man
durchführen wenn die person in der lage
ist ihm zu folgen ist und sich auch die
voraussetzung
bei hoher gebrechlichkeit oder geistigen
fitness dann gibt es kein verfahren ist
es auch klar aber wenn die gegebenheiten
so sind dass die person ein verfahren
verfolgen kann und dann soll das doch an
durchgeführt werden sagt im hanf
erstreckung würde ich dann sagen da ist
man dann aus humanitären gründen groß
was erwartet man sich denn da aber dann
von einem verfahren als solches also
zeugen können ja kaum mehr gehört werden
wahrscheinlich es wird jetzt wann dann
beugt sichere vergebt akten
letztendlichen versucht zu
rekonstruieren was zum beispiel diese
frau getan hat als sekretärin oder was
dieser wachmann getan hat ist ja ist es
das so zu sagen was man dann sehen wird
also es gibt in diesen diesen verfahren
auch immer nebenkläger so hat es
jedenfalls in den bisherigen verfahren
gegeben also es gibt schon überlebende
und es gibt opfer die ein interesse
daran haben dass das sozusagen ihr das
unrecht dass die alten haben hier
festgestellt wird
und ja man man kann eben sozusagen auch
das system konzentrationslager besser
verstehen noch auch aus historischen
gründen sozusagen besser verstehen und
man kann eben gerichtlich feststellen
dass unter diesen und jenen umständen
strafrechtliche verantwortung entsteht
und das hat eben auch auswirkungen auf
die zukunft ja also auch auf andere
situationen jetzt hoffentlich nicht in
deutschland aber anderenorts man sagt
wer sich nicht widersetzt sondern hier
mit arbeitet und zahngold zählt oder
konten der ss verwaltet hat und so
weiter der macht sie strafrechtlich
verantwortlich für das gesamte
unrechtssystem was in einem
konzentrationslager herrscht ich glaube
schon dass wichtiges signal noch einmal
noch einmal ist und darüber hinaus auch
wenn es 90 oder verführen 70 jahre 76
jahre her ist auch individuelle schuld
feststellt das ist ja auch daneben zu
untersuchen hat diese person damit
gewirkt was hat sie alles gewusst wie
hat sie sich eingebracht und das ist
auch nach einigen jahrzehnten immer noch
guten und war bei uns kein verkehrt
genau richtig das war ja die
grundsatzentscheidung die man damals
getroffen hat in den 60ern dass man sagt
gesagt hat dass da machen wir eine
ausnahme
weil eben das unrecht also oder der
tatbestand mord ebenso gravierend ist
dass wir hier keine verjährung eintreten
lassen wollen vielleicht doch zum
schluss also auch damals heute wie
damals im grunde genommen ist ist ja die
argumentation wahrscheinlich oft die
gleiche nämlich auch die sekretärin
irmgard f behauptet sie habe habe von
den gaskammern nichts gewusst
glaubt man so was heutzutage nach oder
kann man diesen
dieses dieses argument vom tisch wischen
einfach nach dem was man eines weiß
einfach vom tisch wischen kann man
natürlich im strafverfahren nichts und
jeder einlassung auch der angeklagten
die muss natürlich untersucht und
hinterfragt werden insofern muss man
gucken wie waren die umstände jetzt auch
die räumlichen umstände in diesem
konzentrationslager kann man sich
wirklich vorstellen dass die davon
nichts wusste also das wird schon dann
alles auf schlüssigkeit hin und
plausibilität hin überprüft ich halte es
jetzt persönlich vielleicht tatsächlich
nicht für sehr wahrscheinlich dass sie
davon nichts gewusst hat aber ich kenne
auch jetzt die einzelnen umstände des
verfahrens nicht das wird man das wird
man genau untersuchen müssen denn erst
einmal muss man auch diese
entschuldigung der angeklagten ernst
nehmen und schauen ob sie nicht
vielleicht doch unschuldig
also das werden noch verfahren seien die
uns beschäftigen ich danke ihnen
wirklich sehr herr professor verlinkt
dass sie uns so wunderbare übersicht
über die letzten jahr 75 jahre gegeben
haben das war hochspannend ja sehr gerne
weiter
[Musik]
kommen wir jetzt also zu einem kuriosen
fall den das verwaltungsgericht
berlin am morgigen donnerstag verhandeln
wird nur wir wollten euch mal ein heads
up geben also ein hinweis darauf dass
das wirklich spannend werden kann für
alle diejenigen die vielleicht auch die
bds bewegung noch nicht so auf dem
schirm hatten das ist etwas was das
vertrauen übrigens schon seit langem
beschäftigt auch da hat übrigens der
kollege simon strauß einen sehr
hörenswerten beitrag im faz podcast für
deutschland gemacht der ist vom 18
august auch den kann ich gerne in die
sonne stellen also von dem kollegen dass
wir uns heute sehr inspirierend weil wir
aber auch viel von ihm gelernt haben
also das geld tatsächlich auch in meinem
fall weil mir ehrlich gesagt nicht klar
war bissig eben diesen podcast gehört
habe angesichts der pressemitteilung des
verwaltungsgerichts berlin
wie sehr diese pds bewegung vor allem
die kulturszene schon seit jahren
erschüttert corinna erzähl uns kurz
worum es geht und warum das jetzt vor
dem vg berlin landet das ist ja fast
noch schräger gerade die bds bewegung
bds steht für boykott investment in
sessions also ist ein amerikanischer
titel und geht zurück auf eine bewegung
die jetzt vom bundestag als
antisemitisch gebrandmarkt wurde
übrigens nicht jetzt sondern vor zwei
jahren schon also im jahr 20 19 also das
ist eine israelkritische bewegung die
ihm zum boykott aufruft zu
investments also zum
dafür fallen dazu aufruft nicht in den
israelischen staat zu investieren und
sanktionen fordert natürlich für das für
den umgang mit den palästinensern
auf dem israelischen staatsgebiet all
das ist nun natürlich grund für ganz
eigene vertiefte diskussion die wollen
wir hier gar nicht aufmachen aber diese
diese bewegung ist ihm extrem umstritten
und zwar so umstritten dass sogar der
bundestag sich damit beschäftigt und ihm
sie für antisemitisch erklärt hat und
dieser beschluss des bundes tages wird
jetzt auch das verwaltungsgericht berlin
befassen das interessante ist man weiß
ja noch gar nicht genau in welcher
richtung eigentlich das wird dann eben
morgen in der mündlichen verhandlung
auch ein thema sein weil es eben unklar
ist ob dieser beschluss überhaupt
irgendeine art von rechtlicher
rechtlicher wirkung entfaltet eine frage
zum beispiel ist ob kommunen dann darauf
reagieren müssen im sinne von dass sie
gar keine verträge mit der bds
abschießen können also sei es für eine
saalmiete oder irgendwie sowas ja also
das ist etwas was noch komplett so es
ging ja in den beschloss nun auch darum
dass das irgendwie der bundestag eben
auch beschlossen hat nicht nur sozusagen
die beschließen jetzt dass das eine
antisemitische vereinigung sei sondern
die haben eben auch verlangt dass die
vereinigung und unterstützer kein geld
mehr von der bundesregierung erhalten so
das klingt ja jetzt erst mal schon so
als könne das durchaus rechtliche
ausgebaut haben aber es gibt so ein
gutachten vom wissenschaftlichen dienst
des bundestags und das sagt dieser
beschluss sei ich zitiere eine
politische meinungsäußerung im rahmen
einer kontroversen debatte ohne
rechtliche
und deshalb ist wohl eben in der tat
noch gar nicht klar worauf eigentlich
jetzt dieses verfahren vor dem vg berlin
gerichtet ist weil eben gar nicht klar
ist ob der beschlossenen rechtliche
konsequenzen hat ob man sich also
bemühen müsste irgendwie diesen
beschluss aus der welt zu schaffen man
weiß ist alles noch nicht das wird wohl
jetzt nämlich also damals vielleicht den
verstärkten blick drauf werfen das
wollten wir hier nur ganz in aller kürze
mal aus tableau werfen und du möchtest
auch noch was aus tableau werfen was
nächsten mittwoch rolle spielt genau und
da geht es vor dem bundesgerichtshof um
den einsturz des kölner stadtarchivs
also ich weiß nicht wie präsent das
sozusagen bundesweit war ich sende ja
hier aus köln und in köln war das im
jahr 2009 schon schon ein echter
kulturschock als herr komplette
stadtarchiv zusammengestürzt ist also da
hat jemand kurz die welt still gestanden
sozusagen damals sind auch zwei menschen
ums leben gekommen
ganz zu schweigen von dem riesigen
kulturellen schaden das war eben auch
ich glaube eines der größten
stadtarchive irgendwie deutschlands also
30 regalkilometer an historischen
dokumenten im grund verschwunden also
das ist ja der kölner südstadt und der
severinstraße und das seid wirklich aus
als wäre eine session krieg
stattgefunden da ist einfach eine ganze
riesige baugrube entstanden und das
gesamte gebäude ist da reingefallen und
ursache waren baumängeln oder was war
genau also es wurde dann auch sofort
gesagt das lag ganz bestimmt an der u
bahn baustelle in der nähe und das war
auch in der tat so also in der nähe wird
auch immer noch eine bahnlinie gebaut
und es war wohl so dass die arbeit da im
jahr 2005 man muss sich mal überlegen
wie lange das alles schon her ist eine
grube ausgehoben haben und sind auch so
ein blog gestoßen den ich weg gekriegt
haben und anstatt das dann zu melden
haben die den einfach den aushub
fortgesetzt und dadurch ist in einer
betonwand unter der erde ein loch
entstanden und durch dieses loch sind an
dem tag als das stadtarchiv nachher
zusammengebrochen ist riesige mengen
sand und kies in die baugrube
eingebrochen und haben alles unterspült
also mehrere gebäude eben auch inklusive
des stadtarchivs das dem archiv wurde
förmlich der boden unter den füßen
weggezogen sozusagen und danach das hat
auch alles jahre gedauert überhaupt die
bergungsarbeiten dass das war alles eine
eine riesen aktion um auch nur die
dokumente aus dem archiv zu holen es
waren natürlich auch mega schwierige
beweissicherungsverfahren also sagt
jahre gedauert bis es da überhaupt
gutachten gab und das ganze hat sich
ewig hingezogen wie gesagt der einsturz
war 2009 und erst im oktober 2018 also
ganz kurz vor der verjährung im märz 19
verdi eingetreten gab es ein urteil vom
landgericht köln es gab eine haftstrafe
zur bewährung und drei freisprüche und
die beiden männer um die es jetzt von
dem bgh geht sind zwei der
freigesprochenen da hat die
staatsanwaltschaft revision eingelegt
und zwar gegen den freispruch von zwei
bauleiter nfon neben firmen die damit
dem bau beauftragt waren die
staatsanwaltschaft hatte denen
fahrlässige tötung durch unterlassen zur
last gelegt aber
das landgericht köln hat gesagt nein die
haben zwar was falsch gemacht also die
haben dinge nicht protokolliert und die
haben eben so zu sagen
ja sie hätten aufmerksam sein müssen und
und hätten mehr auch weitergeben müssen
dann andere unternehmen von den
problemen die da im ganzen kontext
dieser wand die dann am ende zusammen
gestürzt ist und noch hatte sie
weitergeben müssen dann auch an
ingenieure aber das landgericht köln hat
gesagt dass das sei eben nicht kausal
gewesen also auch wenn die alles
hinreichend dokumentiert hätten und ihre
hinweispflicht alle wahrgenommen hätten
dann hätte auch das nicht verhindert
dass der dass der ein schuldenland und
damit auf den tod der beiden menschen
verändert und die freisprüche werden
jetzt vom bgh überprüft genau die
staatsanwaltschaft ist in revision
gegangen zu lasten der angeklagten und
sagt die anzeichen für bau vieler seien
extrem deutlich gewesen und die
bauleiter hätten das erkennen müssen und
in dieser grube hat probleme gegeben die
wieder richtig gedeutet noch richtig
dokumentiert worden sein so und das wird
der bgh jetzt also erneut überprüfen bei
der mündlichen verhandlung im juli hat
der vorsitzende richter schon gesagt es
sei ein extrem komplexer sachverhalt wer
sich die mühe macht einmal in dieses
urteil des landgerichts köln beim
zuschauen kann das nur bestätigen also
seid hinüber seiten technische
technische fragen weil da geht es
natürlich viel weniger um rechtsfragen
als um ganz viel technik also man darf
sehr gespannt sein wie das jetzt ausgeht
das ist der verhandlungstermin in der
kommenden woche also da ist es sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass schon ein urteil
kommt und außerdem ist es auch nicht das
einzige verfahren sondern vor dem bgh
sind glaube ich sogar noch drei weitere
verfahren anhängig nein pardon es sind
zwei und zwar ein bauüberwacher der ist
verurteilt worden wegen fahrlässiger
tötung und ein oberbauleiter der hat
auch eine bewährungsstrafe bekommen die
verfahren sind abgetrennt und laufen
alle noch aber ich hoffe das ist jetzt
nicht nur aus kölner sicht ein
relevantes verfahren denn das war
wirklich damals schon einen moment wo
die welt still gesteuert werden können
das fand ich auch wirklich ziemlich
ergreifend damals
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir noch zu einem nachtrag
in sachen lohnfortzahlung genau jetzt
ist es langsam so weit
es gibt zwar keinen offiziellen
starttermin aber im laufe des monats
oktober wollen die bundesländer den den
beschluss der gesundheitsminister
umsätzen der ersten november 2021 ist
als spätester termin vorgesehen und ab
spätestens diesem zeitpunkt soll ist
keine entgeltfortzahlung mehr geben wenn
ungeimpfte in quarantäne kommen wir
haben das in der folge 178 sehr
ausführlich vorgestellt deswegen
verweisen wir darauf gerne ich habe mich
auch in der folge ein wenig aufgeregt
und ich hoffe dass ich das nicht heute
schon wieder tun muss es geht also nur
und es liegt ja in deiner hand pia ich
gehe nicht im bluthochdruck zustände zu
verfallen hier also noch mal es geht nur
darum dass wenn jemand in quarantäne
muss und nicht geimpft ist soll
derjenige jetzt keinen lohn mehr
bekommen es ist klar was dahinter steckt
also die politische message ist
sozusagen mehr druck auf ungeimpfte
auszuüben und so der gedanke der
dahinter steht ist natürlich dass die
solidargemeinschaft die eben bisher
entschädigung bezahlt hat also auf
deutsch gesagt der staat der
entschädigung bezahlt hat wenn jemand in
quarantäne musste der wird das in
zukunft nicht mehr übernehmen sondern
die ungeimpften sollen dann eben keine
lohnfortzahlung mehr bekommen wie gesagt
ausführlich besprochen in folge 178 da
gibt es auch durchaus noch so einige
weitere fragen denn es ist gar nicht so
unbedingt klar ob nicht die arbeitgeber
trotzdem weiter zahlen müssen also ob es
dann tatsächlich so ist dass am ende
irgendwie die das bei den ungeimpften
arbeitnehmern hängen bleibt der schaden
oder nicht bei den arbeitgebern das ist
alles noch relativ rätselhaft und
genauso rätselhaft ist und deswegen
haben wir noch mal aufgegriffen was denn
eigentlich mit dem datenschutz ist
dennoch ein paar wochen weiter zurück
als die folge 178 hatten wir das thema
ob es denn überhaupt eine pflicht von
armen und arbeitnehmern geben kann ihren
impfstatus im unternehmen offen zu legen
ihr erinnert euch das wurde bundesweit
heiß diskutiert jens spahn hatte gesagt
er kann sich das vorstellen am ende kam
es nicht sondern es gibt eben nur seien
sehr sensible bereiche altenpflege
krankenhäuser arztpraxen wo jetzt eben
die diese extrem sensiblen
gesundheitsdaten erhoben werden dürfen
wo also die mitarbeitenden sagen müssen
ja ich bin geimpft ich bin nicht geimpft
weil ansonsten in anderen betrieben gibt
es diese pflicht nicht und jetzt finde
man den fehler sozusagen und jetzt hat
sich nämlich der datenschutzbeauftragte
in baden württemberg zu wort gemeldet
herr stephan bringt der glaube ich auch
schon hier im podcast ja nicht total
fertig sehr richtig das war eine
legendäre sendung
gestellt ersten ja da hat er das war
wirklich toll geht nochmal ganz zurück
an die anfänge dieses podcasts war sehr
sehr früh als die datenschutz grund
vorahnung noch acht ganz jungfräulich
war und ist viel
viel
viel unklarheiten gab und da hat er uns
mal eine schneise geschlagen eine ganze
stunde lang war schön gewesen gut aber
jetzt hat er hier auch eine schneise
geschlagen und das hat er dann gesagt
genau der hat zu recht wie ich noch mal
anmerken möchte sehr deutlich beklagt
das doch ziemlich wichtige fragen vom
gesetzgeber offen gelassen worden sein
und hat in seiner pressemitteilung
geschrieben das ist sicherlich kein
zeichen guter gesetzgebung also ein groß
er hat s like von pia lorenz ich finde
das auch wirklich sehr skandalös dass es
hier im prinzip eine nichtumsetzung gibt
durch den gesetzgeber also stefan brink
gibt jetzt in einem positionspapier
folgende tipps für arbeitgeber quasi
arbeitgeber dürften den impfstatus der
beschäftigten abfragen meint der
datenschutzbeauftragte von baden
württemberg so denn er sagt eben das ist
ein wichtiger grund weil man als
arbeitgeber ja wissen muss ist derjenige
der jetzt in quarantäne geschickt wird
ist der jetzt hilft diesem zusammenhang
ist er könne sehr berechtigten nachdem
impfstatus zu fragen das soll also ist
es gehe nur um die frage wenn jemand in
quarantäne geschickt wird und der
arbeitgeber ja dann wissen muss ist
derjenige jetzt geimpft ungeimpft
ramallah oder wenn er ungeimpft ist
warum dann muss er das ja irgendwoher
wissen können so das heißt stefan bringt
meint der arbeitgeber darf in diesem
meint in diesem fall darf der
arbeitgeber nachfragen so und wenn er
dann daten bekommt freiwillig von den
beschäftigten dann darf er die auch
nutzen muss sie aber nachher wieder
unverzüglich löschen und darf sie
selbstverständlich nicht für andere
zwecke verwenden denn es ändert sich ja
nichts daran dass gesundheitsdaten
hochsensible daten sind oder es kann ja
zum beispiel sein dass man nicht geimpft
das aus guten gründen weil man sich
einfach wegen bestimmter krankheiten
oder wegen der schwangerschaft oder so
nicht impfen lassen kann darf sollte und
das muss natürlich sofort wieder
gelöscht werden wenn es überhaupt
freiwillig bekannt gegeben wurde jetzt
kommt aber der witz arbeitgeber dürfen
zwar fragen aber die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer müssen nach ansicht von
stefan bringt zumindest nicht antworten
sie sind also auch in diesem kontext
nicht verpflichtet dem status oder
andere erkrankungen offen aber man muss
ehrlicherweise machen sagen das macht
meine als mitarbeiter wenn dein chef
fragt also ich meine wenn du ein echter
impfgegner bis dann kann ich mir schon
vorstellen dass die überzeugung so weit
reicht dass man das tatsächlich auch
macht nur und sich da einfach weigert
will man es kann sozusagen
ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass da
schon ein erhebliches konfliktpotenzial
vorhanden ist stefan brink weist auch
darauf hin dass die arbeitnehmenden
dadurch natürlich am ende nachteile
erleiden könnten wenn sie eben nicht
mitwirken dann kann es natürlich auch
sein dass der arbeitgeber sagt ja gut
wenn du mir hier keine auskunft details
dann zahle ich dir jetzt erst mal
sicherheitshalber nicht den lohn weiter
denn im moment ist es eben so dass die
arbeitgeber den lohn zahlen und sich
bisher das wieder zurückgeholt haben vom
staat nur das ist also in aller regel
die ausgangssituation so also da sind
die ratschläge von stefan bringt er sagt
das ist alles eine mehr als missliche
situation weil keiner weiß was jetzt
eigentlich für wien geld und er hat noch
einen anderen ratschlag nämlich seine
idee ist dass arbeitnehmer stadt ihren
arbeitgebern auskunft zu erteilen über
den impfstatus und eben vielleicht auch
über weitergehende krankheiten die
entschädigung vom staat selbst bei der
zuständige behörde verlangen können ihn
also nicht gegenüber dem arbeitgeber
sondern direkt zur behörde gehen
inwieweit das allerdings praktikabel ist
da habe ich ziemliche zweifel dran weil
wie gesagt der normalfall ist das
erstmal der arbeitgeber weiter zahlt und
sich dann das geld vom staat zurück holt
wenn es denn vom staat geld gibt und
stefan bringt sagt eben auch selbst
schöne idee es gibt aber das kleine
problem dass die behörde zumindest in
baden württemberg eine eigene
antragsbefugnis von arbeitnehmern
verneinen das heißt da kann ich zwar zur
behörde gehen und sagen ich hätte gern
eine entschädigung weil ich jetzt in
quarantäne muss man sagt aber die
behörde möglich war schön zu deinem
arbeitgeber also es ist alles ein
riesiges chaos und das ist jetzt nur die
rechtslage die im stefan bringt damit
dem im sehr eigenen gespür eben auch für
für relevante themen aufgegriffen hat in
einem einzigen bundesland und das
dasselbe chaos herrscht noch in allen
anderen weiteren bundesländern es ist
wirklich ich bin gerade sehr sehr
glücklich dass ich nicht in einer
rechtsabteilung sitze wohl
personalverantwortlichen oder die leute
aus der buchhaltung da sind und sagen so
lorenz was zahle ich denn jetzt hier an
wie ein aus von den mitarbeitern eine
katastrophe ist katastrophen kann auch
jeden tag dankbar sein wenn man als
arbeitnehmer und als arbeitnehmerin
nicht in quarantäne muss dafür kann man
sowieso dankbar sein und an der stelle
auch noch mal gerne verwiesen auf die
weko kinder immer sagt wahnsinnig klugen
hörerinnen und hörer also falls ihr da
erfahrungen habt oder ideen habt oder so
wie er damit umgeht von arbeitgeber oder
arbeitnehmerinnen seite freuen wir uns
sehr wenn die uns dazu schreibt
unter einspruch podcast faz.de könnte
man an dieser stelle sagen und dann
kommen wir jetzt aber zum gerechten
urteil
[Musik]
wir haben ja dann doch eine sehr
gewichtige sendung heute hinter uns und
kommen jetzt zu der grundsätzlichen
frage darf man polizeieinsätze film mit
der hatte sich das landgericht osnabrück
beschäftigt und pia kann ich vielleicht
hier aus dem nähkästchen plaudern kam
schon als ich ihr das thema
vorgeschlagen habe so nach dem motto ist
auch über alt und so aber ich sage immer
man kann auch dinge nicht oft genug
wiederholen die praxis relevant sind her
und die einem vielleicht das eine oder
andere mal im alltag beschäftigen zum
beispiel wissen auf die muss geht und
dass dazu randale kommt ja kann ja mal
passieren
das motiviert mich jetzt und wie zu
nachfragen machst du das auto genau auf
demos gehen auf dem es dann zu
ich darf man hier sehen kann ich gerate
über in dem aus ich bin letztens
wirklich mit dem auto und kinder im
gepäck in eine verbotene querdenker
demokraten das soll echt nicht lustig
und die woche drauf waren dann die
bandidos dran also da waren wir dann am
brandenburger tor sind in eine sozusagen
so so bandidos nicht es sind doch diese
rocker insel java gelegen hatte du
kennst die dass das schlimmer oder
weniger schlimmer oder weniger schlimm
als die querdenker die waren sehr
friedlich die man das ja das sind ja
rocker sind ja häufig wie friedlicher
als man so denkt allerdings dürfe man
ihnen nicht den falschen situationen
begegnet und haben ein wenig vom thema
ab was ich sagen wollte also wir in
solchen situationen kann es ja macht
wichtig
ob man ein polizeieinsatz
filmen darf und da können wir jetzt ein
bisschen rechtshilfe geben also wie
gesagt war so ein fall vor dem
landgericht osnabrück
da ging es darum dass jemand in der demo
war ich weiß noch nicht mal was ist
eigentlich war und der hatten sich quasi
an dem polizeieinsatz gestört und
derjenige hat dann auch geschämt und so
weiter und schob war sein handy weg es
wurde beschlagnahmt und das da wir gegen
wollte er vorgehen und hat vor dem
amtsgericht erst gescheitert und jetzt
hat er aber recht bekommt vor dem
landgericht osnabrück und das fand ich
gerecht und auch einen schönen fall
einmal zu erklären wie die sachlage ist
und vor allem wie die rechtslage ist
erzähl doch mal wie die polizei
eigentlich in diesen fällen immer
argumentiert und mal kurz darauf
hingewiesen die polizei die ja in vielen
fällen mittlerweile selbst filmt naja so
sehr für die polizeibeamte sind ja
mittlerweile mit bodycount ausgestattet
das heißt filmen in aller regel
geschehen selbst aber es ist eben immer
noch so ein bisschen ich will nicht
sagen common sense ist wird auch glaube
ich mittlerweile an den polizeischulen
wirklich auch anders gelehrt aber sehr
sehr vielen polizeibeamtinnen und
-beamten wird schon in der ausbildung
noch beigebracht sozusagen handys zu
beschlagnahmen die auf sie gerichtet
werden und das rechtliche argument ist
immer dasselbe
persönlichkeitsrechte die sagen sie
dürfen mich hier nicht filmen denn das
verletzt man persönlichkeitsrecht und
die
schützen sich dann auch auf das kunst
urheberrechtsgesetzen und auf den 201
stgb stellt nämlich die verletzung der
vertraulichkeit des wortes und der
strafe
übrigens hier auch noch ein kleiner
hinweis hatte ich mich sind jeder hinter
geschrieben deswegen ist es übrigens
immer wichtig wenn man dass man dem
anderen wenn man ihm aufnehmen möchte
also auch tonaufnahmen aufnehmen möchte
bescheid sagt wissen viele leute nicht
mehr insbesondere die jugend die
heutzutage immer gerne mal stimmt oder
aufnimmt und so und hh lustig ist aber
tatsächlich eigentlich strafrechtlich
relevant ja das nun mal hier als ein
lebensnaher tipp gegessen aus dem alltag
von frau wu trasse genau und es
natürlich auch für journalisten immer
relevant verdienen auch immer alles
aufnehmen aber das nur am rande und die
haben sich jetzt hier angeguckt das
landgericht osnabrück wie sieht es denn
eigentlich aus mit dem 201 stgb
vertraulichkeit des wortes also im
öffentlichen raum und die haben eben
ziemlich deutlich gesagt der spielt hier
keine rolle denn das ganze ist sozusagen
eine öffentliche veranstaltung gewesen
ja da gibt es so etwas wie eine
vertraulichkeit nicht kann es nicht
geben und deswegen gab es schon kein
straftatbestand und deswegen gab es
natürlich auch kein verdacht einer
straftat und deswegen durfte auch das
handy nicht beschlagnahmt werden das war
sozusagen die argumentationskette die
jetzt das landgericht osnabrück bemüht
hat der mann hat also sein handy wieder
bekommt also in der argumentation kann
man da glaube ich dann relativ vielen
stellen reingehen aber wie gesagt das
ist immer noch ganz umstritten und wird
von der polizei auch durchaus noch so
vertreten dass man sich eben auf den 201
stgb stützt der schützt aber eigentlich
eben nicht öffentliche äußerungen das
ist das was du sagst gucken anna also
das ist sozusagen bei einer öffentlichen
beim öffentlichen ereignis wiener demo
dann per se schon mal nicht gelten kann
da könnte man aber natürlich gegen halt
na ja wenn ich dann aber keine ahnung in
der nacht und nebelaktion von
polizeibeamten angehalten werde und da
ist sonst keiner der eben zuhört dann
wäre es quasi eine nicht öffentliche
äußerung und dann dürfte ich eben wieder
nicht filmen obwohl gerade keiner da ist
der irgendwie etwas mitbekommen könnte
finde ich relativ schwierig es gibt eben
auch die argumentation dass man sagt
dass jede dienstliche äußerung eines
polizisten gegenüber einem bürger oder
einer bürgerin ein öffentlich
gesprochenes wort ist und damit gar
nicht schon gar nicht erfasst wird von
der entsprechenden stramm unterschrift
also das finde ich eigentlich persönlich
tragbarer weil ansonsten müsste deshalb
je nach situation wäre es einmal
zulässig und einmal unzulässig mit dem
handy zu filmen und es wäre ausgerechnet
in den situationen unzulässig wo sonst
niemand da ist er ein möglicherweise
problematisches verhalten auf seiten der
polizeibeamten dann irgendwie bezeugen
könnten da aber es ist wirklich extrem
umstritten das ist in fast jedem
einzelnen tatbestandsmerkmal umstritten
und ist ein sehr spannendes thema
deswegen gefunden das urteil schön um es
nochmal mitzubringen ich musste dann
corinna auch irgendwie schnell zustimmen
als sie sagt es ist doch aber sehr
lebensnah und das thema ist ja wirklich
schon sehr sehr alt und seit ewigkeiten
umstritten aber es ist eben immer noch
nicht geklärt und von daher kann man
noch mal darauf hinwirken wenn jemand in
solche verfahren verwickelt ist oder so
dann ist es vielleicht hilfreich wenn
man diese verfahren auch mal weiter nach
oben treibt damit man da mal eine
grundsatzentscheidung und vielleicht um
das noch einmal deutlich zu machen hier
ging es auch nur um quasi filmaufnahmen
auf dem handy und das handy wurde dann
beschlagnahmt diese ganze was ich jetzt
mit dem kunst urheberrecht genannt hatte
und auch mit diesen
persönlichkeitsrechten das spielt erst
an der rolle wenn man die sache auch
veröffentlicht also auf
install postet oder auf twitter oder wie
auch immer also das vielleicht im
hinterkopf behalten und damit belassen
wir es auch bei dem rechten unter der
woche und verabschieden uns dann jetzt
gibt es noch etwas zu sein wir hoffen
sehr uns hat auch der der ausflug in die
welt der reichen und schönen mit britney
spears ein wenig spaß gemacht freuen uns
wie immer über feedback und eine volle
woche schönen rest doch auch in mir bis
dahin tschüss
[Musik]